abortion abortion abortion Planned
Parenthood wants you to know they offer
the highest quality health care and most
affordable prices
really Planned Parenthood that's the
[ __ ] you're going with you guys are
starting to sound like a bad used-car
salesman hey folks come on down the
crazy paid abortion barn where we offer
abortions at lowest prices guarantee
people often ask me Pete why do they
call you crazy Pete well that's because
I for abortions and prices so low people
think I'm crazy I'm so sure that if you
want abortion at a cheaper price in the
Greater Dallas Fort Worth area I'm just
gonna give it to you yeah sanctity of
life all I care about is quality
abortions at affordable prices
first trimester second trimester partial
birth thanks to Obama we're getting them
out and we're passing the savings on the
year so what are you waiting for go
crazy Pete that's me at five five five
five four five five that's great to beat
divorce mornin five five five five four
five five crazy piece of butcher bar
killing babies and slashing prizes it's
sick your marketing murder will
targeting lower-income underprivileged
families you sick moms it's a sick thing
to do no I don't think you should have
the right to kill your child oh my gosh
stay out of my bad realm Oh trust me
there is no place I'd rather avoid
it's nothing personal just that you're
very likely overly promiscuous don't
tell me what to do with my body I'm not
but if we agree that that is a child we
can tell you what to do with his or her
life we can however tell you what you
can do with our tax dollars how would
you feel if I reached in your pocket
took that money and use it to purchase
tools that will be used to beat my child
mercilessly my personal favorites the
wooden spoon devastatingly effective are
you starting to see where we're coming
from
everyone's been praising President Obama
for his famous line and we are willing
to extend a hand to those who are
willing to open a fist
apparently that line only applies to
known terrorists and not the baby whose
fists could be wrapped around your
little finger are we not supposed to
help them they don't need
and you know most Americans consider
themselves pro-life it's not that there
aren't enough of us out there is that
we're not doing anything all kidding
aside if you value life leave a comment
share this with your friends check out
the links next to me you might be
thinking yeah but can we really make a
difference as Bob the Builder always
says yes we can yes we can yes we can
where else have I heard that wait a
minute